niveles que podrían acercarse a las
cifras prepandémicas eeuu le da la
bienvenida a una de las épocas más
turísticas del año la celebración del
día de acción de gracias y a pesar de
que los números sobre el coi 19 en el
país son menos preocupantes que el año
pasado los casos van en aumento sólo el
domingo se reportaron 31 mil 372
contagios nuevos y la administración de
seguridad del transporte de eeuu
pronosticó las cifras de viajeros entre
el 19 y el 28 de diciembre
la administración de seguridad del
transporte espera que los puntos de
control de seguridad de los aeropuertos
en todo el país estén ocupados durante
el próximo periodo de viaje del día de
acción de gracias la ts a espera
examinará unos 20 millones de pasajeros
durante las vacaciones de acción de
gracias' dos de las compañías aéreas más
importantes del país también anunciaron
sus previsiones del está prevé 300 por
ciento más viajeros que el año pasado
mientras que united airlines anunció que
el volumen de pasajeros será de un 88
por ciento con respecto a 2019 unas
cifras que han llevado los expertos a
alertar sobre la necesidad de adoptar
medidas de bioseguridad wind y tenemos
que tratar a esas personas que no se han
vacunado totalmente como personas que no
se han vacunado totalmente that center
and win it had si debemos tomar
precauciones sobre ella como los due
mascarillas en lugares cerrados y quizás
tomarse un test rápido en gráficas
este lunes el gobierno descartó cierres
de las actividades económicas pero
recomendó a sus ciudadanos no viajar ni
alemania ni a dinamarca